I was 12 years old it was 1975 and there
was the apollo-soyuz link-up now I was
just starting to get an international
perspective on politics and all of a
sudden here was something that was
really quite different this was really
exciting this was now two sets of people
on both sides of the Iron Curtain who
had clearly come along with different
views from the past thought they were
working with the same laws of physics
they were adapting what their systems
were so the Russian systems the American
systems they were having to communicate
adapt their own system so that they
could achieve something successful in
space and then when am I saw on
television on the 17th of July in
Madison Drive the hatch was opened and
Tom Stafford the Mexican of shook hands
there was this overwhelming joy that was
absolutely palpable between these two
people 40 years later on the occasion of
Tom Stafford's 85th birthday he chose to
spend that day in Moscow and
enough and that really is inspirational
on so many different levels in so many
different ways space in spy
you